I love fishing I grew up fishing
especially on the river say I'm a solid
didn't catch much however just that
excitement that little bit of magic that
little bit of adrenaline what's under
the water what will it catch the South
has 3,000 kilometres of coastline and
bank waters making it the best place to
go fishing in Thailand I'm hooking up
with one of the most experienced
fishermen in the region Sartre how are
you good to see what is that thing there
it's our hapu have a quick look please
look at that my gosh look at it that's
incredible so that's the fish but they
look amazing look at the size of them
Yosh the shells it's like a paving stone
oh my God look at it
unbelievable what is the noise of this
size taste on you should try and catch
him yourself and you taste it then you
know always this way that big ready
let's go
that's amazing
this is beautiful we're fishing for
super-sized Easter's on the beds of
these back waters but Sartre expects
they'll put up a fight what in the hell
is that for and a chisel yeah you use
this side that one there for what for
Easter for oysters how deep down are we
going on previous is only a family okay
great ready
the trip to the oyster hotspot is
heavenly no crowds no stress just
beautiful countryside
oh is that are you
Wow Sartre eventually stops in what
looks like the middle of nowhere but
this is the spot where he makes his
biggest catches but I can't see a thing
the tie time and the waters murky
mistake sir no not sneak as we continue
to dive down things eventually become
clearer
with South's help I try to knock it off
the rocks but I run out of breath we
take an axe to a bloody oyster okay
I was seriously chuffed it's in perfect
condition I haven't cracked the shell
and I've never had gone down diving
process let alone with the chisel an axe
one I'm admiring my oyster czars making
quick work of the rest of them beautiful
we open it now yeah
Wow that looks like oh that looks
amazing you mind yeah
how was it
[Music]
I didn't think it would be that firm it
was almost like it was it was cooked but
it was clearly raw but you know and
oysters get that firmness when they've
been lightly poached incredibly meeting
but very very sweet I'm dying to see
okay
house art and these friends gonna cook
these back at the village site has
invited over a great local cook called
yaa she's going to show me the Thai way
to serve oysters and an amazing fish
soup so we're gonna make a classic
normally we break bang bang bang bang
amazing that's ray we have to bang yes
yeah there's no need for knife skills
with yars
tom some soup into the pot yeah the
lemongrass onions and turmeric will form
a classic Thai aromatic stock so that's
just plain water in there she then adds
some fresh local fish heads in fish
sauce sugar yeah
and then this one and finally an
essential sudden sour ingredient palm
vinegar Oh trees born three spoons from
here Oh sour and spicy so that's the
main characteristics of the southern
Thai cuisine hot and sour yeah
the final part of the fishy feast is a
delicious dipping sauce for oysters it
starts with a paste of course made of
garlic coriander root chili and salt
then limes and fish sauce and that's the
dipping sauce done a little bit I can't
wait to taste our efforts
first up oysters and dipping sauce good
I'm finally the fish soup very very nice
thank you so much those oysters were
delicious thank you I'll be sad to leave
his laid-back paradise but I've learned
all I can time to put into practice it
was phenomenal
no dried ingredients anywhere all fresh
ingredients lime leaves galangal
turmeric ginger garlic delicious and
then think back home were crying out for
healthy easy food to prepare give me
Thai food any day